- All right, let's finish
up with something cool
and different trending on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
An Iowa banker is trending on TikTok
for one of the most unusual
hobbies I've ever heard of.
He cleans and restores graves.
Wade actually visits cemeteries
all over the country,
removing mold, repairing
cracked and broken headstones
and bringing back the dignity
to those who have passed.
It's such a beautiful thing.
We have him on the line right now watching
on KCCI Des Moines.
Hi, Wade, how are you doing?
(audience cheering)
- Hey, Kelly, it's awesome to see you.
Thanks for having me.
- [Kelly] No, thank you
for what you're doing.
It's such a beautiful thing.
But how did you get into this?
- (laughs) Yeah, it's
an interesting story.
It was from my grandfather.
So like 25, 30 years ago,
we were having a family reunion.
And after the picnic lunch,
we went over to the cemetery,
and he said, "I think we should try
and clean the headstones."
And we were looking at the family,
and it was my great-grandfather
and other relatives.
And so he said it, but we
never followed through.
So years later, I learned to
clean, I learned to reset,
and then it really snowballed
into nearly a million
followers on social media.
And in 2022, I traveled
20,000 miles over 16 states
and I really self-funded a
big project of trying to clean
and restore as many graves as possible.
- That's such a beautiful thing to do,
for not only those that have
passed, but their families.
It seems so meaningful for the families,
but you say it's also meaningful
to you as well, right?
- [Wade] It is, it really is.
Alicia in your earlier
segment was talking about
a mentally safe place
in cleaning up parks.
For me, it was seven years ago,
I was in grad school and I
was addicted to Adderall.
And after recovering from that,
I was looking for a place and a way
to continue a mentally
safe place, peaceful,
and so I got into working in cemeteries.
And it was just an amazing space for me
to be able to share that with my followers
and reflect and remember other people.
Everyone has a story
no matter who they are.
And so working on their graves,
discovering who they were,
and then sharing that with my followers.
And so it's been really awesome
to be able to see the descendants
of those people show up in my comments
and just be so excited to see the work
that's been done restoring and caring
for the gravestones of the
people that have passed.
- What, first of all, thank
you for sharing your story,
and what an incredible
thing to find purpose
and passion out of something
that's so difficult
and challenging to overcome.
Way to think outside of yourself
and do something amazing for other people.
I'm such a fan of you, Wade.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- [Wade] Awesome, thank you, Kelly.
- Well, and that's not all, my man.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the "Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, man,
so they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
- Oh my God, thank you so much.
I really appreciate that.
That is gonna be amazing.
Gonna put that to good use, thank you.
- [Kelly] Aw man, thank you, Wade.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Giancarlo Esposito, Brandon Scott Jones,
Priyanka Naik, Hailey
Whitters, and Alicia.
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not, try and change it.